What's the difference between lumbro kinase and nanokinase and the pancreatic enzymes that Dr. Gonzales used for cancer?
So it's the type of enzymes. So there's different enzymes that break down different things.
The enzymes that Dr. William Ellie used, and then Dr. Gonzales learned from him, and then I actually learned from Dr. Gonzales.
So Dr. Gonzales was one of my instructors, a great guy.
And he was more of a cancer clinician. Dr. Kelly was an orthodontist who actually helped heal his cancer by using proteolytic enzymes.
So proteolytic enzymes are enzymes that break down proteins.
And there are enzymes that break down mainly carbohydrates like amylase.
And enzymes that mainly break down fats like lipase.
There's a lot of different forms of enzymes.
And nanokinase and nanokinase are known to help kind of clear the blood and clean the blood.
And then some of the kinases that Dr. Gonzales really got, it started helping work in a goblet of lacking on the inside of arteries.
The problem is that when they've done studies on some of these, some studies are positive, and some studies are negative.
And then they don't really show much improvement at all.
But I really do believe this is just my opinion that some studies were set to be negative, meaning that they used a poor source of nutrient in their study.
That's just my opinion. They were purposely, they were funded by the pharmaceutical companies to fail.
But I do think that, you know, there are good forms of enzymes. There's and bad forms of enzymes.
Enzymes are a very heat sensitive. So you got to be careful if you have a bottle of enzymes.
If you leave about a year car in the summertime and they heat up at your car, you probably destroyed most of the enzymes in that bottle.
So you want to keep your enzymes protected from heat. You want to keep all your nutrients protected from excess heat, but definitely enzymes enzymes will degrade quickly.
I've said in other podcasts, there's some supplements that basically have, you know, an endless shelf life.
One would be minerals. Really don't degrade over time. If you took a bottle of a good quality mineral from a good supplement company, 30 years ago, it probably have 98% efficacy too as well.
Anti-oxidants don't degrade. So if you have supplements that use antioxidants in them, some supplement companies put basically put canalace and superoxid.
Disritace basically in every product. One of those companies would be biotics research. They use, it doesn't make them a better company, but they tend they use kind of as their base.
Canalace and superoxid. Disritace, so it's in literally every supplement that they have. Well, one of the positives of that basically extends the shelf life of that product to, you know, decades beyond its expiration time.
Well, minerals are, excuse me, enzymes are not that way. So enzymes will degrade over time. They're the most easily thing, easy thing to degrade with heat.
And enzymes are specific to what they will break down. So lumbarokites and nanokites that have blog posts on both of those what they do, how they're used to the body, you would not, you know, take high doses of lumbarokites and nanokites to break down the way slayer around a cancer.
You use proteolytic enzymes. So it's just the right use of an enzyme. So you use it, if you're trying to use a digestive enzyme to help break down food, you'd use a more broad spectrum digestive enzyme, like US enzymes digest times plus or are clear digest, which is a more broad spectrum.
An enzyme to break down food, but you wouldn't use our clear digest to help break down as a high dose to break down the way slayer around a cancer. You'd use a proteolytic enzyme.
So just going to use your enzymes wisely. And I will say, you know, at the time that Dr William Kelly was using enzymes that was back in the 1960s, there just wasn't very many enzymes on the market. So he settled on the pancreatic pork enzymes.
And that's what Dr Gonzalez used was the allergy research brand, pancreatic pork enzymes.
Now the negative of that is that you take a ton of them and he would use in his enzyme therapy, people would be taking upwards of 150 capsules a day.
It's a lot of capsules to swallow. It could be very difficult.